Nate good morning thanks for joining us
how are you I'm doing good thanks for
having me okay so you heard Chris long's
quote that rugby players are
legitimately crazy a rougher sport you
play both what do you think I don't know
about crazy well maybe that's just a
little bit of a misunderstanding but um
no I mean there's there's things about
both of them that make them very tough
it just depends on what your definition
of toughness is really to me if it's
about how hard you hit somebody I'd say
footballs probably gonna take that one
just because the physicality of the game
but on their aspects to rugby which are
extremely tough when it comes to
cardiovascular standpoint the amount of
mileage that we have to run in such a
short period of time but you also tackle
and get back up and then compete um
there's a very tough aspect of you know
cardiovascular fitness that is in rugby
especially rugby sevens that you don't
see in in football the difference in how
you feel the next day after a rugby
match or a football game here's what
well sometimes in a rugby match you know
you got the bangs the bumps and bruises
but usually fairly healthy um football
is getting this just depends on how the
game went and what kind of hits you
Pacey I mean it takes one big hit in a
football game that you can you feelin
first you know almost a week up until
the next game so it really just depends
but i would say the things about our
rugby are as you know you don't have any
equipment and things of that nature so a
lot a lot more times you'll get and
bumps and bruises but a lot of cuts so
people see the blood they think you
crazy but you know justice is not you
know I'm breaking a bone or perrita leg
room or something internally what did
you play first football rugby rugby I
grew up playing rugby at a really really
up family members plant yeah my dad
played you start
in college but the rest of his life
after that really came into the culture
of rugby and you know growing up for me
i was around and watching his games and
stuff that was something that brought me
close to the game and pick it up at a
really young age and played a lot of it
and got the you know join the medication
has a kid please when i was little so I
had to you know run from from the older
guys that uh that's that I've got sorry
for me he's Nate Ebner the Patriot
safety special teams player and a member
of Team USA rugby sevens squad the Rio
summer olympics what did bella check did
you have to clear this with Bill
Belichick to be able to play in the
Olympics oh yeah I mean I not only him
but you know the rest of the pages
organizations we had lots of
conversations about you know my desire
to come dry try to be partying with this
so you know many many conversations were
at and ultimately they stayed back me
the entire way and getting their
blessing and um you know from shimla
thankful and grateful that they gave me
this opportunity because without that
blessing I don't know that I'll be here
how would grow Gronkowski be in rugby I
mean how would Dom be at anything that
is physical as well I think that answers
that he's a beast she would have no
problems uh what was the bet that you
won against brady did you did you win a
bet uh I don't know why you're referring
to did he have to wear in ohio state
jersey were you were you involved in the
was at ohio state michigan holly oh uh
yeah every year with robbery games guys
like to have you know little bets
between each other admit some sometimes
it's just you know where t-shirt
something of that nature nothing nothing
too crazy no means all had a little i
had to get him finally for the AA state
michigan game you never wants to never
wants to see me on that gas or some
reason by the way how how good is Team
USA you guys contend for a metal
definitely content for middle on no
doubt was finished in the world in the
World Series this year we've beaten all
the top teams ahead of us um multiple
times this year just hasn't accrued
enough points to be higher than chest
but I'm even in the last tournament we
beat PG who's number one and also newsy
on tues no top 3 as well so we
definitely have the ability to beat the
top teams um I wouldn't say we're
frontrunner at all so not you know
winning the series but we're definitely
contenders if anyone right so sasa you
know the mistaken for sure well good
luck heading over there Nate perhaps
I'll see you over there and good luck
when you get there yeah thanks so much
all right Nate Ebner me Patriots safety
special teams member and now Team USA
with rugby the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience